all right so first today i am going
as i lay out the case of they're going
to try to scare the hell out of you
people
i'm going to now conor do we have the
warning i'm going to show you something
from the view okay content advisory what
you're about to see yeah it's going to
be scary but believe it or not
uh i'm going to start what you're going
to see here to start i don't want to tip
away too much but you're going to see
the start is joy behar making sense
which is very very weird joy behar is
going to make sense then sunny hassan is
going to take it away but joy behar is
going to make sense uh but the theme
really here is that biden scares us and
we should not trust any of these people
anymore and when i say any of these
people i mean fauci i mean the cdc i
mean the who i mean the world economic
forum i mean the buffoons on cnn the
crazy people on msnbc and certainly
the harpies at the view
it's a
match
npr doesn't want the covert to spread
yeah so they're telling their people if
you're a fellow employee sitting there
without a mask i want to hear about it
report it to hr i think i would never do
that on italian we don't snitch
look i think it's a good thing because
we've been terrible to each other during
this uh pandemic i i think you know
remember patty lupone was was
at the theater and she had to really
dress someone down a theater goer and
saying you know protect us we're here
without our mass our audience is all
mass because you guys are protecting us
because we cannot be masked right now um
and and i think you know there are times
when you want you see someone let's say
on an airplane when we had the the mask
mandate and they had the mask basically
you know around their ears like earrings
or like chin guards and if you said
anything they would fight you about it
and this the flight attendants had to
say stuff so i i just think you have
this this mechanism now where you can
just call
and snitch
and protect yourself as opposed to
taking it on yourself
somebody just snitching on somebody they
don't like
my god i can't believe it joy behar
and what's her name anna cabrera
actually made some sense we'll get to
sunny in just a second joy behr i'm not
going to snitch on people now first off
joy behar would snitch on people right
she's a crazy leftist maniac there's
just no doubt that if her makeup woman
and the woman cakes on a lot of makeup
if the makeup woman came in without a
mask of course joy would be snitching so
it was a joke but uh whatever i'll give
joy a little credit on that one and anna
navarro
my god she said something sensible there
at the end how do you know that people
wouldn't just snitch on people they
don't like that's interesting anna
navarro you got one right it's i don't
know what's going on here but now let's
do sunny hostin who is a complete idiot
she's a racist by the way um she seems
to think that people should snitch on
each other at work and that it is your
responsibility
to
make sure that other people take medical
precautions that you see fit not just
that you should be responsible for
yourself so if you want to take whatever
precautions you want and if you want to
wear a mask and if you want to wrap your
head in saran wrap and put a ziploc bag
on and industrial strength tape around
it and all that stuff that's your
position but that also you should be
making sure that other people who don't
do the things that you want them to do
are potentially fired
so the point of all of this is why would
we listen to these people as this monkey
pox thing seemingly is disseminating and
what i mean by that is it's
disseminating through the media more
than anything else i'm only talking
about it today because i want everybody
to freaking calm down about it more than
anything else but these people it just
goes to how if you just scratch
you just scratch a progressive what's
underneath that thin layer up top is a
real authoritarian they really really
want to control you she really wanted to
control those people on planes instead
of just putting on a mask herself
and just letting it be right she really
wanted to control people